Brian and eight on your side tonight on
average there are almost a hundred
infant deaths every year because of
unsafe sleep environments involving a
nursery product Kirsten Joyce tells us
what new products but new parents and
new grandparents should be looking for
most of those deaths occurred in cribs
and bassinets and play yards where there
was the presence of other products
that's why it's critical for parents and
caregivers to develop a game plan for
keeping a baby's sleep space safe first
things first put your baby in a sleep
sack the wearable blanket keeps little
ones warm while lowering the risk of
Sids the risk is highest during the
first year of life but especially in the
first few months before babies start to
roll over the consumer product safety
commission has the following important
guidelines to share when it's time for
bed place your baby on their back always
to reduce the risk of Sids as well keep
the Sleep space bare use a firm flat
surface with only a fitted sheet no
pillow bumper or comforter which can
suffocate a baby if they fall asleep in
a swing bouncer or a lounger transfer
them to a firm flat crib and finally
incline products like rockers gliders
and swings should never be used for
infant sleep more than 2 million baby
swings and Rockers manufacture by baby
gear maker for moms have been recalled
recently over a strangulation risk
following the death of a 10 month old
infant this recall applies to mamaRoo
baby swing as well as rockaroo baby
rockers there is a strap that is used to
secure babies to those two products when
the baby's in the product it's not an
issue when the baby is not in the
product and the strap is hanging it is
it is a potential strangulation Hazard
for babies that may be crawling